[Music]
brooke is in claremont florida hey
brooke what's up
hi how are you
so my question is i have a 20 21 honda
release
i actually just quit my job because i
couldn't take it anymore and honda's the
only one that can pay off my lease
um i just don't know what to do
obviously i need a car i don't know if i
should finance something
through honda because they'll give me my
payoff if i
have them buy it i'm kind of stuck i
don't know what the best thing to do is
wow how much is your car payment it's
6.78
wow i can't breathe
and you quit your job so you have no
income
i do um i got a serving job actually so
i how old are you 23
uh i'm 24. 24. yeah
almost like i've done this before
um
wow
you got to be pretty scared right now
kiddo
um you know
he's there for me we've been dating for
a while we just bought a house so
i just
know that my car
he just got a house
i mean we got it together i'm on the
deed but
it's his house yeah
it's not if you're on the deed it's not
well yeah this is our house yeah guess
so i guess you're in a partnership
with somebody you're not married to
okay um
there's a lot a lot here so so what i
want you to do is go get a kbb jump
online to kbb and find out what this car
is worth not what the dealer says it's
worth
and then i want you to find out from
honda what the early buyout on the lease
is the used car market has gone bonkers
and it's very possible you can get
enough out of this car if you sold it to
an individual to pay off the lease
okay that gets rid of the disastrous
mess that has called your car
your car deal honey is cray-cray
it's over-the-top nuts
and it was exposed when you quit your
job but it was already crazy before you
quit your job yeah what you're making in
payments right now you could save up in
a few months and get a better car to get
you around yeah go buy a thousand dollar
car with cash drive that for a month
then go buy two thousand dollar car with
cash drive that for a month then go buy
three thousand dollar car with cash
drive that for a month then go buy a
five thousand dollar card you're gonna
be able to do that once you get working
again but you gotta get to working and
you gotta get rid of this payment
and i don't even wanna start on you
about buying a house with somebody
you're not married to you have gotten
yourself into a mess there also
it just remains to be seen so
get married please george i i feel a
little bit like we didn't have enough
time to address all the things going on
in that young lady's life so i think
three things stuck out immediately in
the call and uh for the rest of you
listening out there here's what our
advice would be
number one
um
never buy a house with someone you're
not married to
yes that can create a whole slew of
problems but like she was saying she's
on the deed
and i don't know her situation on the
mortgage but if this relationship
doesn't work out this is a nightmare and
someone's getting kicked out of their
home
yeah and they're also going to continue
to own a home that they no longer live
in and possibly be on the mortgage and
so basically what you formed in legal
terms is a general partnership and you
have no partnership documents
when you are married there's a whole
group of laws that surround your rights
protect you when you are
two single people buying a house
together you are forming a general
partnership and if you don't have
general partnership documents there is
nothing to dictate what happens
and so uh he beats the crap out of you
and starts doing cocaine kills your dog
and you run off into the distance you're
on a mortgage with him
and you own a house with him and you
can't do squat about it
you're stuck
maybe it's not as severe as that maybe
it's not as bizarre as that but you will
you are stuck
so if you're gonna shack up one of you
by the house the other one be the one
that's gonna leave when this doesn't
work
okay and and you're free then and
they're free but there's no mechanism
like in a divorce there's a mechanism
that forces what happens with the
ownership of the house the
disillusionment of the assets of the
marital assets but there is no mechanism
for this unless you spend
you know twenty thousand dollars going
into civil court and legal fees to get
this disbanded so it's just a nightmare
it's also a relational nightmare it's
also a lot of other things that are dumb
but in addition to that you just set
yourself up in a financial credit and
legal
mess yeah okay number one number two if
you're upside down on a car you owe more
on it than it's worth and you have a
ridiculous car payment that you
shouldn't have bought and some life
event occurs that tells you that
um the way you get out of a lease is
a lease has an early buyout that is
different than the total of all the
payments
okay you can't just add up all your
payments plus your residual value at the
end you call and get the early buyout
because that is in effect
it's like getting an early payoff on
your loan
when you pay a loan off three years
early because you're selling it you
don't pay interest on all of those three
years and a lease doesn't technically
have interest but has cost of capital
built in and so they re it is a reduced
amount when you pay it off early an
early buyout so you need that number
it's your payoff figure and you need
what the car is worth
in today's weird world for the first
time in 30 years of doing this show you
might actually get more for the car than
the early buyout is because of how used
car market because the inflated prices
on the cars and so in with hurlo honda
let's say that little honda sells for
38 000 and the early buyout is 36
thousand dollars then you could sell it
to anyone for thirty eight thousand
dollars but you have to give honda the
thirty six thousand dollars which is the
early buyout you put two in your pocket
in that case get you a beater car if the
early buyout is thirty six thousand you
sell it for thirty four thousand
you gotta come up with two thousand to
pay the lease out so that the new buyer
can get a clear title you do not have to
sell it to honda yeah and you don't want
to go one option from a frying pan into
a fire and go finance another car if
you're getting out of a mess you go get
a beater a garage sale car um that has a
horrible color
and is mechanically reliable and you pay
750 for it at a garage sale and it's a
1974 ford okay but it drives perfectly
and you're not you're not going to keep
this car you're going to give it a name
and you're going to tell your
grandchildren what you used to do back
in the day back in 22 i drove a car that
was bird egg blue we called it old blue
you'll be telling your grandbabies this
someday and this is the kind of car you
need to buy when you're getting out of
this mess
number three
don't quit your job
unless you have another one lined up
she's relying on the boyfriend at this
point now you're really trapped you got
honda around your neck you got him
around your neck you got a mortgage
around your neck and you're going to get
in panic mode and just like we were
talking about before we picked up the
call with her as soon as i get desperate
i get stupid
so i want you listen unless you're being
harassed physically or asked to do
something criminal
i just couldn't take it anymore that's
not an ex no you don't quit you suck it
up buttercup
and stick it out two more weeks for your
i can't take it anymore and go get you
another job doing something before you
just walk out cold yeah and that's the
power of the baby steps is you have
options when you follow these steps and
you're debt free you got the emergency
fund you can breathe and you might be
able to quit that job and step into
something else and ken coleman talks
about that all the time bringing the
boat close to the dock and having a plan
it would take it would take 48 hours to
land another job in this world
and you and you're you're gonna
interview different while you still have
that job take some of your
vacation time and go interview i take it
there too often go pto time whatever it
is and go interview go get something
else landed
um you know see you
so
proverbs says he who is impulsive
exalts folly
folly
i have been impulsive and i have exalted
folly
what that means is a folly is a is the
verb of a fool in action
so when i am impulsive i am by
definition a fool in motion a fool in
motion i like that and so uh you know
impulsive is not
i i i just live free no that's just
immaturity
and whether you're 54 or whether you're
24.
and so i'm not picking on her i'm just
saying some of you listening out there
these are some life lessons you should
listen to this show because it's
entertaining thank you but you should
also walk away from the show every day
going i just learned something
i want to be less foolish and a little
more wise that's my hope less impulsive
yeah yeah a little more grown up i'm
gonna slow down just a little bit i'm
not impulsing a car i'm not impulsing a
house with a boyfriend i'm gonna quit my
job because i had a bad day you know
little just calm your butt down
i mean really
this is this is this just i feel so sad
for her she's just got a mess on her
hands and i'm not picking on her y'all
um because i was a lot worse than her
when i was 24.
a lot worse that's not that's not the
point the point is if we're going to
listen to this stuff we need to get the
what are the nuanced lessons out of this
rather than just be aghast
at how bad the situation is